Marjorie Young:
Community House is an organization that was founded back in 1969, and it was founded by
a group of students who were very interested in making a difference in the local community.
Marjorie Young:
So -- if you can imagine a group of Princeton students back in '69 going into the community
and actually living there and establishing relationships with parents and grandparents
Marjorie Young:
and children and actually going into the school system and meeting people -- so, it was really sort of
a very nice sort of grassroots situation where people really made real connections with the
Marjorie Young:
people they worked with.
So, that's something that Community House has retained. We are still very much in the
Marjorie Young:
community. We work with the local schools. We work with churches. We work with summer camp
programs. So, we continue to have great relationships with the community partners, as well as the parents.
Marjorie Young:
But since '69 a lot of things have changed. So, in the beginning the students provided
just basic tutoring help and some recreational activities. Now, we have a whole range of programs,
Marjorie Young:
ranging from our sustainability summer camp, we have science programs, we have engineering
programs where kids are using Legos and building and thinking about the different aspects of engineering.
Marjorie Young:
People ask me the question, "How does Community House impact undergraduate students?" I've
had a lot of students who started out in one career path, and then end up with Teach for
Marjorie Young:
America or our program here, the Program in Teacher Preparation, so all of a sudden you
see this curve, because they're like, "Wow, this really matters to me, and I want to do
Marjorie Young:
something to make a difference."
We have a Generation One Program, which is a high school program. This program started
Marjorie Young:
in 2000, and we have students who have graduated from the Gen One Program, and they're
now in college. Now, I'm always cautious about saying that Community House is the reason,
Marjorie Young:
but we know that we have impacted them in their desire to go to school, either because
we provided an SAT prep class or because we took them on college tours.
Marjorie Young:
We really are striving to impact the minority achievement gap in a very tangible way. It's
the issue where minority students tend not to do as well in school as the majority population.
Marjorie Young:
And so at Community House, we really focus ourselves on thinking about what are the issues involved
with this problem, how can we utilize Princeton resources, how can we utilize undergraduate
Marjorie Young:
students, alumni, community partners? How we can leverage all the resources to make
a big difference and make a change in this problem?
Marjorie Young:
The minority achievement gap isn't going to be changed overnight, but it certainly will
be changed one student at a time and that's our mission at Community House, is to make
Marjorie Young:
a difference one student at a time.